Pixar's new movie Cars 3 will be racing onto
the big screen this summer and we've just
got the latest details on the new and returning
characters we can expect to meet.
We know from the first teaser trailer that
Lightning McQueen suffers a catastrophic crash
that will lead him to reassess what his future
really is.
And pushing #95 off the track is an upcoming
generation of cars armed with bleeding-edge
technology that can slice through the competition.
Let's take a look at the car leading this
new wave of racers, Lightning's new rival
Jackson Storm.
Jackson Storm is the face of the new generation
of racing cars and he's been "trained on high-tech
simulators" and programmed for perfect technique
and maximum speed.
Storm is a confident and cocky young rookie
whose Piston Cup sponsor looks to be IGNTR
and whose racing number is 20.
Storm can outrun McQueen with a top speed
of 214 mph and can make zero to sixty in just
3.6 seconds.
He's voiced by Armie Hammer who you'll have
seen in numerous movies including The Lone
Ranger, The Man from UNCLE, and The Social
Network.
Helping Lightning to find a way to compete
in this new world of cutting-edge tech will
be his new trainer Cruz Ramirez.
And here she is:
Cruz is an unconventional young trainer who
leaps at the chance to work with her hero
Lightning McQueen when he arrives at the Rust-eze
Racing Center.
Cruz understands all the new technologies
that have helped rookies like Jackson Storm
rise to the top, and she decides to work with
Lightning to help him find a successful way
back to the racing track.
The duo practise and train together during
the off-season to prepare Lightning for the
Florida 500 event.
Cruz is voiced by Cristela Alonzo, a stand-up
comedian, actress and writer who starred in
her ABC sitcom Cristela, and whose voice you'll
hear in the animated Angry Birds movie.
And returning to voice the 5-time Piston-Cup
champion Lightning McQueen is Owen Wilson.
So let's take a peek at Lightning in Cars
3.
It's been rumoured that this movie could be
#95's final appearance on the big screen and
that Cars 3 could be slamming the brakes on
the Cars franchise.
One thing's for sure though, with Lightning's
top speed being 198 miles per hour, which
is nearly twenty below Jackson Storm when
he's at full throttle, Lightning will need
to learn some new tricks from his trainer
Cruz if he plans to stage a winning comeback
on the track.
So guys, what do you think about the new characters
in Cars 3?
Are you excited about the movie and do you
think it could be better than Cars or Cars
2?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this video, your support is
really appreciated so do please like it, share
and subscribe.
And you can click any of the links here to
check out more of my Pixar videos on Finding
Dory, Inside Out and The Good Dinosaur.
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!